[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition du 7 8 journal sur tv 78 nous
sommes le jeudi 6 septembre tout de
suite les titres de l'actualité un
nouveau programme immobilier d'ici
l'automne 2020 à guyancourt 63 logements
en accession vont sortir de terre dans
le quartier du pont du rotois l occasion
de parler de la politique de la ville en
la matière avec notre invité stéphane
olivié maire-adjoint de guyancourt en
charge des projets urbains sa présidente
sophie legrand sera en plateau familiaux
wanted oeuvre pour sauver les chats
abandonnés les soigner l'association
cherche également de nouveaux foyers à
ces animaux rescapés elle organise à
partir de demain un week-end d'adoption
c'est au magasin animalis de maurepas et
puis le portrait de la semaine est
consacrée à cette cible ynwa qui est née
il ya plus d'un siècle à 110 ans michel
chevalier le doyen d'ile-de-france nous
l'avons rencontré dans sa commune saint
rémy les chevreuse elle met d'abord la
visite aujourd'hui de muriel pénicaud a
dû en cours la ministre du travail s'est
rendue sur le tout nouveau campus des
services de l'automobile et de la
mobilité
le site de douze mille mètres carrés a
ouvert ses portes en cette rentrée
sur place quatre organismes de formation
pour préparer à l'ensemble des métiers
des services de l'automobile
il est 10 13 il existe treize domaines
d'activités du commerce au contrôle
technique en passant par le dépannage à
plus de 130 mille entreprises agissent
dans ce secteur et nous reviendrons plus
largement sur cette visite demain dans
l'émission dû 7 8 l'hebdo présenté par
nicolas landry stéphane ollivier est
avec moi sur ce plateau bonsoir en soit
vous êtes le neuvième maire-adjoint de
guyancourt en charge des projets urbains
63 logements en accession vont sortir de
terre est d'ici 2020 dans le quartier du
pont du rotois vous avez signé un accord
en ce sens en ce sens pardon je vais y
arriver avec deux sociétés pour la
réalisation de ce projet pourquoi
était-il nécessaire pour la ville de de
faire construire ces nouveaux logements
ce qui est toujours une demande de
importante de logements sur la ville il
faut savoir que statistiquement si on
ville de la taille de liancourt doit
construire 110 logements par an juste
pour que sa population reste la même
parce que vous savez il ya les enfants
quittent le foyer parental parfois
maladroitement des couples qui se
séparent et qu'il ya besoin de nouveaux
logements rien que pour rester au même
nombre d'habitants dont à une forte
demande de logements est avec un coup on
a toujours voulu avoir un parcours
résidentiel sert une diversité dans le
type de logement des logements locatifs
sociale des logements en accession libre
et ce qui est le cas de cette opération
la des logements en accession aidée
c'est à dire que ce que nous avons voulu
faire dans un quartier où il ya beaucoup
de logement social donc pour apporter de
la mixité et bien c'est d'offrir qui
arrive une offre de ce qu'on appelait le
don des deux logements en accession à
prix maîtrisés dire que c'est des
réservé à des gens qui pour l'instant ne
sont pas propriétaires noms qui peuvent
devenir propriétaire la ville a vendu le
terrain parce que c'était un terrain sur
lequel il y avait un préfabriqué qui
nous servait plus la ville donc avant a
vendu ce terrain à un promoteur à un
prix moindre que celui du prix du marché
en contrepartie le promoteur s'engage à
vendre lui aussi aux acquéreurs un prix
maîtriser et à réserver cette offre à
des gens qui ne sont pas encore
propriétaires qu'ils ont de pouvoir
devenir une vraie volonté pour la ville
de favoriser l'accès à la propriété d'un
avion courtois vous l'avez dit c'est
aussi dans un quartier qui est en plein
développement c'est le pont du rock
thouars que la ville s'attache à
développer depuis plusieurs années ça
crée un quartier qui a été créée je le
rappelle en 1972 pourquoi c'est
nécessaire de d'agir dans ce quartier
alors produire au toit quand on compare
à aux autres quartiers de nuit en cours
il ya toujours qu'ils sont plus récents
que le conducteur ne prend pas des plus
anciens comme le village mais soit le
parc les sols quartier de l'europe
villeroy et toujours une volonté qui est
une mixité sociale
dire qu'on a du local comme je disais du
locatif social de l'accession et tout ça
vit ensemble et le quartier du pont
montoir m'ont fait au début des années
70 c'est pas du tout cette logique au
départ c'est les hlm de versailles qui
sont déplacés une partie de la chaîne de
versailles qui sont déplacés à
guyancourt et c est aussi isolé pendant
la zone voilà donc tout le travail qui a
été fait c'est un travail de très longue
haleine ça avait commencé à l'époque de
romans d'ados voilà c'était déjà de
reconnecter ce quartier au reste de la
ville
et puis d'y apporter de la mixité c'est
ça qui a eu la place cendrillon le
quartier des marges à ricky qui touche
qui a lui aussi donc apporter de la
mixité sociale et donc plus récemment
une nouvelle opération qui ont été
faites dans l'emplacement où il y avait
autrefois en une entreprise de
menuiserie donc un promoteur avait
acheté ces terrains on a travaillé avec
ce promoteur qui voulaient au début
construire 200 sans réfléchir tout pour
qu'il ya un véritable aménagement la
construction d'un groupe scolaire une
résignation unique également une
résidence intergénérationnelle et qui
rendent en fonction de la clinique de
soins de suite voilà qui est une vraie
vie qui soit sur le quartier voilà on
veut aussi où ils redynamiser ce
quartier en faire tout simplement un
quartier de guyancourt parmi d'autres et
bien qu on est aux alentours des 50 % de
logements sociaux il sait ça là l'idée
aussi c'est de pouvoir équilibrer de
proposer vous le disais tout à l'heure
une offre vraiment large ce
il se chiffre de 50% nous semble un bon
chiffre sur l'ensemble de la commune
mais on va même que la loi vous impose
25 ans et vous savez qu'il est minime je
pensais plus des deux tiers des
habitants d'ile-de-france ont un revenu
qui les rend éligibles au logement
social donc c'est nous 50% ça nous
paraît un bon chiffre mais à condition
que ce soit qui militait qu'ils se
fassent rue par rue et pas d'un côté un
quartier on met tous les hlm et puis
l'autre côté à un quartier où on met
tous les propriétaires des déceptions
quartier d'ailleurs qui ont aussi leur
identité vous disiez le village le
centre-ville finalement de guyancourt
casse côté village hérité du moyen-âge
c'est vraiment des quartiers avec des
identités fabrique chaque quartier de
lui en cours d'eau si des quartiers dont
qui sont qu'il a deux des débuts de la
ville nouvelle qui ont aussi maintenant
une identité propre
ça fait 40 ans et et les gens sont
attachés à cette identité
donc nous on est on est pour qu'il ait
une vivre ensemble partout sur le
territoire de la commune donc c'est pour
ça que là où il ya beaucoup de logements
sociaux mais on est plutôt enclins à
développer l'accession à la propriété
nous reste un peu moins de deux minutes
trois mois ce programme de 63 logements
il ya des plaquettes de présentation qui
sont disponibles en mairie en mairie va
y avoir une réunion début octobre aussi
d'informations donc bah invite tous les
ménages soient si vous habitez
guyancourt si vous y travaillez que vous
souhaitez devenir propriétaire mais pour
l'instant aux truites le coup
l'immobilier est trop élevé pour vous
peut-être que ce projet il vous qui a
primé être plus maîtrise que ces 3500
euros du mètre carré
il vous permettra d'être de devenir
propriétaire donc aller vous renseigner
et d'ailleurs vous pouvez retrouver les
informations sur le site de la mairie de
lui en cours il ya des critères
d'éligibilité aussi pour bien grâce à
logements de revenus mais qui a qui est
celui du
du logement social + 11 % d'accord on
retrouve bien sûr là ces informations
sur le site de la ville de guyancourt
merci stefano l'idée d'avoir été avec
nous bado rien et je rappelle que vous
êtes le maire-adjoint aux projets
urbains à guyancourt est la société du
grand paris aura un nouveau président
demain les 21 membres du conseil de
surveillance doivent élire le nouveau
président de cet établissement public il
est chargé de développer le grand paris
express ces nouveaux métros en
ile-de-france dont la ligne 18 notamment
des deux candidats sont en lice dont le
président est l'ère du département des
yvelines pierre bédier soutenu par ses
homologues franciliens face à lui
patrick braouezec nommé membre du
conseil de surveillance par décret cet
été et qui a les faveurs de l'état
urbanisme toujours mais à elancourt ou
les jardins familiaux des quatre arbres
sont menacées de disparition un
collectif d'une cinquantaine de mandat
de cinquantaine de membres a été créée
par des habitants il défend donc ce
jardin collectif qui est arrivé dans les
années 1970 dans la ville le projet de
construction du futur commissariat de
l'agglomération est prévue en lieu et
place des jardins que la municipalité
souhaite relocaliser un autre endroit
le collectif se mobilise tout au long du
mois de septembre pour la sauvegarde de
ces jardins et une pétition a déjà
recueilli plus de 1000 signatures propos
collectées par patrick jacques de
dixmude c'est pas un combat
d'arrière-garde
aujourd'hui plus personne ne veut manger
des choses qui sont pas corrects qui
sont qui sont pas clean qui sont pas bio
tout le monde rêve de manger bio bien
que tout le monde n'en ai pas les moyens
parce que c'est quelque chose qui
revient très cher je me dis qu'il faut
pas rater ce à quoi il ya des tas de
communes de la vie de nouvelles
qui sont partis là-dessus qui préserve
les terres qui justement médecins en
valeur et puis ici on va mettre tout ça
en l'air alors que c'est un véritable
trésor
et concernant le projet d'aménagement de
la zone d'activités des quatre arbres le
groupe d'opposition au conseil municipal
elancourt ensemble pour l encours
organise ce jeudi soir un débat c'est à
l'ancienne mairie de là ville à partir
de 20h30 un autre jardin collectif à la
verrière à lui accueilli un anniversaire
plus haut pour clôturer la célébration
de ses dix ans l'association à des
dalles a réuni des adeptes autour de la
tomate le week-end dernier une
exposition de différentes variétés de ce
fruit rouge ont rythmé l'été ont rythmé
par dont les festivités retour avec
marylène iapichino et patrick jacques de
dixmude d'origine bosniaque ou russes de
couleur rose ou orange
la tomate se décline sous de multiples
variétés pour fêter ses 10 ans
l'association dédale l'âme est à
l'honneur avec l'aide des passionnés de
la plantation du jardin collectif de là
derrière
je suis venu pour échanger avec les
autres
pour échanger au niveau des graines ou
les tomates les produits mais aussi
échanger des idées
il ya des expériences diverses et
variées on apprend toujours
la star de la journée a de quoi rougir
tous parlent d'elle et la décortique
pour la découvrir dans ses moindres
détails
il essaie de repartir avec quelques
graines des tomates qui vous plaît et de
rencontrer ceux qui les ont élevés
c'était matelas et qui vous les offre
l'occasion d'échanger de précieux
conseils notamment pour récupérer ces
fameuses graines de fer moitié au wat et
vinaigre et je laisse tromper toi comme
ça moi je mets juste de gélatine
hélas cet échange autour de la tomate ce
n'est qu'un exemple des actions de
l'association de la co-organisation de
festivals alternatiba à la verrière à la
création d'une amap attrape les membres
ont rappelé l'étendue de leur réussite
en disant nous avons toujours cherché à
soutenir les initiatives positives à
créer un réseau de confiance sur le
territoire et à faire collectif avec
toutes les bonnes volontés prêtes à
s'engager pour des alternatives éthique
design et qui ne demande qu'à être
poursuivis prochain rendez vous le 10
novembre pour les ripailles des repas
débat sur le thème des solidarités à
maurepas
ce week-end vous pourrez venir en aide à
des chats en détresse des journées à
d'adoption sont organisées ce samedi et
dimanche c'est au magasin animalis de
maurepas et s'est organisée par une
association du à territoire family
wanted bonsoir sophie legrand vous êtes
la présidente de cette association on
parle dans un instant de cet événement
est aussi de vos actions sur le
territoire family wanted a pour but de
sauver les chats abandonnés de les
soigner de le retrouver aussi un nouveau
foyer
au sein de cette association beaucoup de
personnes qui ont le vrai pour la
protection animale pourquoi créer cette
association nous nous sommes rendus
compte qu'il y avait énormément de
demandes de sauvetage et toutes les
associations sont saturés et n'ont plus
de place pour faire face à la demande du
coup on sait on a aussi lancé on a créé
notre association on a recruté plein de
bénévoles et des familles d'accueil
et voilà nous apportons notre pierre à
l'édifice
nous avons toujours besoin de familles
d'accueil parce que les demandes sont
vraiment vraiment bregeon le reçois tous
les jours et tous les jours on est
obligés de refuser des sauvetages de
laisser des chats à la rue par manque de
familles d'accueil et aussi par manque
d'eau par manque de moyens on aura
l'occasion de repasser un appel aux
bénévoles à la fin de cet entretien
alors on sait que le problème de
l'abandon explose au moment des départs
en vacances quelle est la situation ici
à saint quentin en yvelines qu'est ce
que vous avez pu observer sur le terrain
beaucoup beaucoup d'abandons d'adultes
évidemment à la rue pas identifié donc
voilà c'est très facile de se procurer
un petit chaton tout mignon qu'on trouve
sur internet ou qui en voisin nous a
donné parce que sa chatte a eu une
portée de pas l'identifier ne pas le
mettre en règle de rien faire et quand
il est adulte et qu'il est gênant dans
le mât la rue et ensuite nous on les
récupère pourquoi faut-il les sortir de
la rue ces chats on a peut-être tendance
à tort a présenté le chat comme un
animal indépendant face à quels dangers
et il est exposé dans la rue lejeune
déjà au service des êtres humains aux
accidents à la fin parce qu'il n'y a
plus assez de nourriture dans les villes
pour les chats il n'arrive pas à chasser
suffisamment pour se nourrir aux
maladies mais il ya voilà le sida du
chat le coz coryza typhus et plein
maladie parce que tout le monde ne
connaît pas mais qu'ils sont mortels
pour les et pour les chats comment
travailler votre association j'imagine
que ça démarre dans la rue justement
pour repérer les chats abandonnés là
alors c'est beaucoup de gens qui nous
appellent qui nous signalent un chat
blessé un chat errant un chat maigre et
ces noms se rendent sur place si on a la
place de prendre associations on le
prend le place en famille d'accueil
il est très important de faire une
quarantaine pour ne pas le mettre en
contact tout de suite avec les autres
animaux on ne sait jamais s'il a des
maladies des choses comme ça et voilà
ensuite on le met en vrai
fais ce qu'il faut que pour lui des
familles d'accueil c'est un rôle
primordial avant que le char retrouve un
foyer lambda était clairement un rien ne
peut pas sortir les chats de la rue
saint famille d'accueil il ya un vrai
manque aujourd'hui de familles d'accueil
de bénévoles au sein de votre
association
donc on peut aussi retrouver toutes les
informations vous contacter sur le site
la page facebook qui s'affiche en bas
d'écran alors des actions sont mises en
place sur le territoire alors notamment
en ce moment il ya une cagnotte qui a
été mise en place pour financer les
frais médicaux de six chatons qui ont
été victimes d'actes de barbarie voilà
c'est ça exactement c'est le mot puisque
à priori selon les constatations du
vétérinaire qui les a vus deux fois à
deux reprises au cabinet les yeux ont
été vains certains vieux ont été crevés
et les paupières supérieures coupe et on
voit des images qui sont assez choquants
douala et comment on peut venir en aide
aux chats quand voilà un chantier qui
est en détresse comme ça quand
quel est votre rôle finalement quand
vous leur curieuse mais déjà de le
remettre sur pattes mais on va aller
soigner on va essayer de faire ce qu'on
peut pour sauver les yeux sachant qu'il
y en a qui vont être énucléé c'est vrai
c'est inévitable les soins vont être
plus long très long
d'où la cagnotte que nous avons assez
parce que je pense qu'il va y avoir pas
mal et d'intervention et après on va
essayer de retrouver des familles digne
de ce nom c'est des frais médicaux qui
sont élevés oui oui alors on le disait
en début de cet entretien vous organiser
un week end adoption ce samedi et
dimanche au magasin animalis de maurepas
quelles sont les conditions pour adopter
il faut passer un entretien avec les
responsables qui valide les adoptions
sur place voilà il ya il faut
s'acquitter de 150 euros de frais
d'adoption s'engager à vacciner l'animal
s'engageait à les stériliser a donné des
nouvelles à l'association ce que nous
faisons un suivi post adoption l'animal
reste au nom de l'association pendant
plusieurs mois et on change le nom du
propriétaire qu'au bout d'un suivi voilà
abouti ce genre d'action sur le
territoire vous les mettez souvent en
place ça se déroule tout au long de
l'année l autre genre d'action vous vous
mettez en place quelle voilà quel type
d'action vous mettez en place sur ce
territoire
la stérilisation des chats sauvages
quand elles sont trop sauvage et qu'on
ne peut pas qu'elles sont pas adoptables
les stérilisent on les identifie on les
relâche sur site où elles sont
identifiées comme chat libre mais
toujours au nom de l'association
combien de familles d'accueil de
bénévoles vous manque-t-il aujourd'hui
c'est compliqué à dire je dirais que en
nature besoin et j'ai pas de chiffres
mais je reçois des appels tous les jours
dès demain de sauvetage tous les jours
vraiment beaucoup plus une dérogation
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter
j'allais dire plus de bénévoles mais
peut-être est-ce qu'il ya des projets
qui vont se mettre en place la dans
l'est dans les prochains mois pour votre
association de grandir j'ai envie de
dire d'avoir plus de plus de dons d'être
d'intérêt général dont kylie dont puisse
être déduits des impôts de 66% pour tous
nos donateurs et je rappelle que ce
week-end d'adoption se déroule donc ce
samedi et dimanche au magasin animalis
de maurepas venez nombreux et pour plus
d'informations sur family wanted vous
avez la page facebook qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci à sophie la bande à
voir et à vivre sieff président de cette
association a family wanted
ce week-end vous ne pourrez pas en
revanche vous rendre au speed park et
des clayes-sous-bois le parc de loisirs
a fermé définitivement ses portes au
public dimanche dernier il proposait
notamment des activités de bowling de
karting ou encore d'arcade
ouvert depuis 2012 le lieu était jugé
trop petit par cette direction qui a
donc décidé de le déménager dans des
locaux plus grands en essonne une
fermeture qui déçoit forcément les
habitués écouter ces quelques réactions
au micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
peu dommage parce que
nous l'hiver ça nous permettait de venir
encore il pleuvait des pas beaux c'est
important de venir visait à quoi on peut
se retrouver tous ensemble on regrette
vraiment la fermeture du discute pas
c'était pas du tout on s'attendait pas
du tout que ça allait fermer aussi vite
mais déjà on était surpris parce qu'on
le savait pas et oui c'est un peu
embêtant parce que de temps en temps
vient de faire un bond ou avec les
enfants
et là on était en train de regarder le
bowling le plus proche ça nous éloigne
pas mal donc c'est embêtant forcément
les directions saint germain en laye le
domaine national du château accueille
jusqu'au 1er octobre une exposition
nommée jardin de mémoire les quatre
artistes ont travaillé avec des
personnes souffrant de maladies
psychiques découverte de ce travail avec
miquel et demi d'euros et nicolas landry
[Musique]
depuis le 1er juillet 12 avons pris
place dans le domaine nationale de saint
germain en laye un projet d'envergure
mise en place par l'association art
convergence objectif créer du lien
social à travers le monde de l'art on a
donc imaginé un parcours artistique et
sa nord dans lequel des artistes
pouvaient travailler avec des personnes
en situation de handicap psychique ou de
difficultés psychiques et d'espagne en
psychiatrie et c'est ce projet et n'ont
donc nés de cette collaboration
pour cette première édition en plein air
les quatre artistes ont travaillé avec
une vingtaine de patients et des
soignants venus des centres d'accueil de
jour de rambouillet et trappes
versailles saint-germain-en-laye
ensemble ils ont imaginé un monde qui
éveille les sens il y en a certains ce
dans lesquels vous pouvez entendre le
des sons priant sous sol par des
captations micro et un d'autres savent
ça marche en alternance l'avons on
s'approche des troènes aider je crois
que ce sont des bruits qui sont derrière
et là vous allez avoir la voix de mehdi
qui va vous déclamer les noms des
personnes inscrites sur le monument aux
morts qui se trouve derrière pour les
patients ce travail mis en place sur six
mois aurait des bienfaits sur leur
bien-être sur le centre hospitalier de
plaisir
du coup ça leur permet de d'exister
autrement que par leur maladie de
pouvoir
exprimer leurs talents artistiques et
d'être reconnus publiquement en tant que
personne entière et non pas que comme
patients souffrant de maladies
psychiques
ça leur permet de reprendre confiance en
eux et des fois de leur faire découvrir
leurs talents artistiques et leur
créativité pour voir leur créativité
l'exposition jardins de mémoire l'art du
partage et à retrouver jusqu'au 1er
octobre assange amendé son film avait
fait à l'ouverture du premier festival à
saint quentin de tv 60,18 cyril dion
était hier mercredi à montigny le
bretonneux
le coréalisateur de demain un million
d'entrées au cinéma participe à une
rencontre organisée par la librairie du
pavé du canal à trois ans après demain à
l'illinois qui est également auteur
vient de publier chez actes sud
petit manuel de résistance contemporaine
en appelle au changement des
comportements pour sauver la planète
mélanie poker et nicolas landry ont
interrogé j'ai essayé de théoriser un
peu sur ce qui s'est passé de comprendre
pourquoi demain avait fonctionné comme
ça ce qui ne continuer à ne pas marcher
dans le dans le mouvement écolo et puis
essayer de faire des propositions
complémentaires et notamment des
propositions de stratégie et donc moi ce
qui m'intéressait beaucoup c'est de voir
que le succès de demain et est entre
guillemets la preuve que quand on
produit un récit quand on raconte une
histoire qui est suffisamment bien foutu
désirable touchante même par rapport à
ces questions ça donne de l'énergie
ça suscite de l' enthousiasme ça
entraîne des gens dans une volonté de
faire des choses libinois cyril dion
acquis l'émission vais y paie sera
prochainement consacré sur tv 78
[Musique]
la saison dernière vous aviez l'habitude
de retrouver ce rendez vous le mardi
désormais le portrait de la rédaction
c'est chaque jeudi dans le 7-8 journal
focus sur les personnalités qui font le
département des yvelines lui à 110 ans
il est le doyen à d'île de france
michèle chevalier est un habitant de
saint rémy les chevreuse récemment il a
écrit un livre revenant sur ses plus est
d'un siècle de vie jules colis la
rencontre et c'est à la maison de
famille des eaux vives à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse que nous
rencontrons un homme aussi souriant
accueillant doyen d'île de france mais
également vice doyen de france michel
chevallier a fêté cet été ses 110 ans un
événement à la hauteur de son
enthousiasme est john r avec d'amérique
et allizard blast est tout et rien d
athées à miers et l'été était formidable
je ne vais pas dire ça mais je me
quotidienne comme le biais les b je
n'arrivais pas d'ennemis c'est beaucoup
un patient modèles toujours prêt à aider
le personnel de la maison tout en
participant à plusieurs activités tout
particulièrement l'écriture
monsieur chevalier est arrivé il ya
maintenant quatre ans dans notre maison
il avait donc 106 ans il est très actif
dans l'établissement il a vite trouvé
ses repères et il a écrit un livre avec
notre art thérapeute
un livre qui reprend toute son enfance
il n'avait jamais écrit un livre de sa
vie
ce projet l'ami aussi sous la lumière
des projecteurs il a été reçu en mairie
il a vendu une centaine d'olive un récit
retraçant la vie d'un homme sur tout un
siècle dans lequel michel nous raconte
ses nombreuses expériences
j'ai changé je dis je partais ovale en
2004 en 2004 michele mis à danser
j'ai lancé par soit encore et c'était
bien
exempt si bien ils ont tellement bien
que deux jours de deux foyers u17 coupe
on est obligé d'appeler les pompiers
c'est un monsieur qui qui a qui n'a
aucune difficulté au niveau cognitif ni
au niveau physique puisqu'il se déplace
très bien avec son déambulateur un
personnage unique et attachant bientôt
arrière arrière grand père qui se résume
lui même mieux que quiconque
et puis lui aussi est centenaire mais
habite montigny le bretonneux marcel
raul a été fait hier mercredi chevalier
de la légion d'honneur remise des
insignes par l'union nationale des
combattants lors d'une cérémonie à la
mairie de la ville marcel raul est
distingué pour ses actes de bravoure
blessé en 1940 par l'armée allemande il
vit encore aujourd'hui avec une balle
dans l'omoplate
on écoute le maire de montigny le
bretonneux interviewé par isabelle
karisko cette légion d'honneur
c'est un événement juste exceptionnel
parce qu'à montini je ne suis pas sûr et
je le sais même n'y a pas d'autres
centenaire en tout cas des centenaires
qui ont fait la guerre comme monsieur
raoul
quant au mois de mai madame raoulx
appelé la mairie pour savoir comment
faire pour cette décoration
j'ai tout de suite pris la voiture je
suis allé les voir pour organiser cette
cérémonie d'aujourd'hui parce que un tel
événement pour moi même mérité un
hommage presque nationale c'est la fin
de ce journal je vous rappelle ce rendez
vous demain sur tv 78 le premier numéro
de la saison a dû à 7,8 l'hebdo où cette
information sera à développer la visite
de muriel pénicaud à guyancourt la
ministre du travail s'est rendue sur le
tout nouveau campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité
le site de douze mille mètres carrés a
ouvert ses portes en cette rentrée sur
place quatre organismes de formation
pour préparer à l'ensemble des métiers
des services de l'automobile
il existe treize domaines d'activités du
commerce au contrôle technique en
passant par le dépannage et plus de 130
mille entreprises agissent dans ce
secteur cette édition allait bien sûr à
revoir sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile le 7-8 journal
revient lundi
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
non